SUDHERRA VANGURI: Did you know
that 80% of enterprise data
is largely
unstructured and 70%--
a large percentage of it-- is
in the form of free-form text?
By free-form text, I mean
we see a lot of enterprises
sitting on dark data.
And this data can be
a document goldmine.
A lot of these documents
are PDFs, emails, contracts,
think comments, tweets,
tickets, patent files,
application forms.
And this data is
only going to grow.
We see that a lot
of organizations
have a strong need to make sense
of realms of unstructured data.
And if you're an
organization that is already
aware of this problem
and you're trying
to analyze these documents
as part of your business
workflows, it's
likely you're spending
a large amount of time,
money, and resources
to analyze these documents.
And the process may
also be error prone.
What if we told you we have
a document understanding
solution that can help
make your life easier
without breaking the bank?
Hi everyone, my name
is Sudherra Vanguri,
and I'm the product manager
for Document Understanding AI
here at Google Cloud.
Today I'll be walking you
through a quick overview
of the solution.
I'll try to unbundle the
solution a little bit,
deep dive a little
bit into what makes up
the solution and the
components of the solution.
I also have some exciting
partner integrations
and stories to
share with you, I'll
also be joined on
stage by [INAUDIBLE],,
the Director of Product
Management at Iron Mountain.
And she'll be talking
about four key case
studies and vertical solutions
that Iron Mountain is
investing in.
We'll also be joined by Milan
Lee, our customer engineer who
will walk us through a demo
of a patent application that
has been processed end to
end from unstructured data
to structured data using
Document Understanding AI.
Let's get started.
So Document Understanding
AI is a solution
that enables you to automate key
document processing workflows
and extract valuable knowledge
from within those documents.
How do we do that?
Well, Document
Understanding AI is
powered by our powerful
natural language
capabilities, knowledge
capabilities, and vision OCR
capabilities.
So unbundling and looking
through the solution
a little bit.
We enable you to come into
GCP or our partner solutions
with unstructured data.
A lot of forms,
patterns, contracts,
and all of those
document goldmine that we
referred to a while ago.
We enable you to
classify those documents,
organize those documents
meaningfully using
our AutoML technologies.
We also enable you to extract
key value pairs and entities
from those documents.
Again, using a combination of
national language, vision OCR,
and AutoML capabilities.
And if a business were
to add your own schema,
we also have
knowledge capabilities
through a new alpha version
called Knowledge Service.
This enables you to construct
a knowledge graph out
of your unstructured data and
map it to your own ERP systems
so that you can start to extract
insights from those documents
and convert that unstructured
data into structured data.
Let me show you a quick demo.
SPEAKER 1: In this demo,
we have a knowledge base
that contains Wikipedia articles
about a wide variety of topics.
In all, there are 48 documents.
One of the documents
is about steam engines.
So here you see the content
of the Wikipedia article
about a steam engine.
I would say I want to know
something about steam engines.
We see in our basic search
we have a result that
matches on some key words,
but it's not semantically
similar to the query.
We go to the semantic match.
We see that the answer matches
the meaning of the query.
If we view it in the document,
we can see where in the article
the passage is coming from.
Another one of our
articles is about Doctor
Who, a famous British TV show.
Let's say I want to know
the plot of Doctor Who.
So I'll enter a
semantically similar query.
In the basic search
results, we don't really
see who Doctor Who is.
But in semantic match, we end
up with a great description
of Doctor Who.
He is the primary character.
He's from a different planet.
And he goes by the
name, The Doctor.
Now let's say I
want to dive deeper
and I want to answer
a specific question.
Search result is poor.
What we see that the
answer to the question
is actually in the document.
And the answer is 826.
826 Doctor Who
installments since 1963.
Let's say we want to
ask another question.
When did it first air?
And sure enough, the
answer is in the document
and we're able to find
it and service it.
SUDHERRA VANGURI: So that's some
of our knowledge capabilities
for you.
Know that we also have a lot
of our custom key value pairs
and custom knowledge
grappling capabilities
so that the same use case can
apply to various verticals
and industries given
your business schema.
So in a nutshell, what document
understanding gives you is,
through our partner
solutions, you'll
be able to organize
your documents,
classify and extract key
value pairs and insights
from within those documents,
and automate your business
workflows using the
extracted insights.
So enough talk.
Let me dive right into some
of our partner solutions,
announcing some of
our early launch
partners, our lead launch
partners, Iron Mountain, which
is fully integrated with the
Document Understanding AI
solution and our capabilities.
We also have key
partnerships and integrations
with UiPath, Egnyte, Box,
Taulia, DocuSign, Accenture.
Let's dive right
into some key use
cases and some
exciting examples.
Our first partner, Egnyte, has
used Document Understanding AI
to detect anomalous
activity of file downloads
on patents, NDAs, and contracts.
Now Egnyte Protect
enables an organization
or an administrator to know when
significant downloads of very
sensitive documents
have happened
over the past couple of weeks.
And the way it does
that is Egnyte Protect
builds a personalized profile of
the common file types accessed
by, let's say, John Smith.
Well, that's entirely
hypothetical.
I don't know a John Smith.
Sorry, John Smith.
But let's say John
Smith accesses
a lot of patent files, 250 odd
pattern files within a week.
Whereas his normal
profile typically
accesses about two to three
contracts, four to five
patents during the work week.
Now with Document
Understanding AI,
Egnyte Protect is able to
classify contracts, employee
lists, invoices, NDAs,
and various document
formats and flag
sensitive documents
when a large file
activity happens
so that insider attacks
and espionage attempts
can be thwarted
by organizations.
That's a cool real
world application
of Document Understanding AI
for sensitive document workloads
that we see applied
to various industries.
Say, HR files, detecting
GDPR compliance,
so on, and so forth.
Another partner application
of Document Understanding AI
was auto-tagging forms using
Document Understanding AI.
DocuSign, our e-transaction
management partner,
has used Document Understanding
AI to detect bounding boxes
on forms.
The key use case here,
let's say we have a W9 form.
We are able to
accurately identify
bounding boxes trained on
thousands of documents.
And also associate
those bounding boxes
with signature fields,
named fields, check boxes,
so on, and so forth.
To go from an entirely untagged
document that was manually
tagged before into
a fully automatic,
tagged form that DocuSign
then has launched
into their mobile applications.
I have a cool demo to show you.
This doesn't have a
talk track, but I'll
try to make sense of it for you.
So let's say we have an NDA
that has a bunch of fields,
a set of five fields or so.
And this NDA needs to
be signed by one party.
So the sender,
let's say tomorrow,
sends this NDA out to Martin.
Now auto-tagging
kicks in and we're
using Document Understanding
AI we'll automatically
be able to identify
what's a date sign, what's
a text field, what's
a signature field.
Now we're using a
combination of NLP, AutoML,
and natural language to do this.
That's it.
Earlier this was an
entirely manual process
that Tamara had
to go and identify
which fields needed signatures.
Using Document Understanding
AI, we are automatically
able to identify when
the word signature is
close to a signature
field, what is a date sign
field versus a [INAUDIBLE]
date, so on, and so forth.
So that's documented
understanding AI,
a powerful combination of
varied technologies using
a combination of NLP, OCR,
and our AutoML technologies.
Another partner,
UiPath, has used
to Document Understanding
AI for automating
their invoice processes.
So here's an example
of an invoice.
As you can see, the invoice
is in a tabular format.
There is a lot of handwritten
text on the invoice.
There is a stamp in there.
So we're able to accurately
identify key value pairs
from within that invoice.
Taking a closer look
at it, as you can see,
we also share the confidence
scores for the key value pairs
that we've extracted
from that invoice.
Now, if there were
a human in the loop,
we also enabled the human to
take a look at the confidence
course so there can be
further downstream processing
on those invoices.
So the entire manual process
of invoice processing
is fully automated using
Document Understanding AI.
A similar use case
around invoice processing
is cognitive invoicing
using Document Understanding
AI that our partner,
Taulia, has integrated with.
Taulia uses Document
Understanding AI
for automatically
extracting invoice data
and using their platform,
their suppliers and buyers
are able to coordinate on
invoices where ever there
is verification needed.
But then a large part of
the invoice processing
is automated using
document understanding.
As Taulia says, moving out
of the dark ages of manual
invoice processing
using the UAI.
Our final partner integration
is with Accenture Saga, an NLP
platform powered by
Document Understanding
AI and some other key
third party solutions,
uses our equity extraction,
knowledge graphing,
and question answering service
to solve key question answering
and document
understanding workflows
for Accenture's customers.
With that, let me hand
it over to [INAUDIBLE]
for a deep dive on
Iron Mountain InSight
and for key case studies.
[? ANKA: ?] Thanks very much.
My name is [? Anka. ?] I am the
Director of Product Management
for Iron Mountain InSight.
And I'm going to tell you a
little bit about our platform
and some use cases that
we're enabling to drive value
for our customers.
So the office experience
and many of us
work with information and we
know what this is like, right?
There's a ton of
data, but finding
the right stuff when you need
it is incredibly hard still.
So this quote, it's from 1982.
All right, think about that.
So we think it's time to fix it.
And our partnership with Google
is really all about that.
Our customers are
at various stages
of digital transformation, which
for them is about driving value
from their information,
transforming
to a new way of
working, and frankly,
reducing the risk
from the information
that they're storing.
There are plenty of
statistics that actually she
mentioned already, right?
So huge amounts of storage.
Very little of that information
actually being used.
And document understanding,
combined with Iron Mountain's
information management
and information governance
expertise, really enables
us to get to a point
where we can, at scale
and as a service,
deliver the value out of
all of that information.
And again, I said we come
from a sort of an information
governance background.
So we are also
focused on making sure
that you can be compliant with
regulations that may apply
to you as you're doing that.
So I'll briefly walk through
some high level information
about the platform and
then dig into the use cases
to show you how that all works.
So the platform, there
are really, sort of,
three steps, if you will.
First is ingestion.
For us ingestion
is really broad.
So we have customers who store
physical information with us.
Could be paper, could be tapes.
And we want to make
sure that we can
allow them to pull all of that
information into the platform
in order to enrich
it and process it.
It could also be digital
information, right?
So ingestion from various
different sources,
from various different types or
forms, and in various formats.
Video, images, documents,
all of those various sources
that Sudherra mentioned earlier.
Second step really then is all
about processing that content.
We built a cloud native
platform on top of GCP.
So we're leveraging
all the power of GCP
in order to store and
process the information.
We're using Document
Understanding AI in order
to classify and
enrich the content.
And really it's all about three
primary use cases, if you will,
at a high level that
we want to drive.
One is around analytics.
How do I now make this
information valuable to a user?
The second is around
information governance.
Now that I know what I
have, what are the policies
that I need to apply?
How long should I keep it?
When do I need to
protect it because it
has personal or sensitive
information in it?
And then the third one is
around workflow automation.
And we'll walk
through use cases that
illustrate each of those items.
In the end, it's
about adding structure
to that big portion
of your content
that is today unstructured.
So the first use case
is in oil and gas.
So we store incredibly
varying types
of things for our oil
and gas customers.
Could be ginormous maps that
get scanned and then processed.
Could be seismic
data that is on tape.
Could be well logs that could
be dozens to hundreds of feet
long.
And we help A, ingest
all of that information.
And then using the
Document Understanding AI,
we extract
information that helps
us, frankly, enable
the geoscientist
to make use of this information.
So all of the various
content, can you
imagine if you're
a scientist trying
to find the information
you need to evaluate where
you might want to drill or what
the value of a certain well is?
You're going across paper
maps at Iron Mountain.
You're going to tape
potentially for seismic.
And one of the challenges
is you just don't ever
know whether you
actually got access
to everything that you need.
So what we're doing here is
processing the information,
again using Document
Understanding AI.
We also can enrich
the information
with external metadata sources.
So it's about pulling as
much information metadata
together from using AI, as
well as from existing sources,
and putting that all
together in a visual search
UI that allows geoscientists
to search for it in a way that
makes sense.
So instead of spending half
your time looking for the stuff,
you can now spend most of your
time actually analyzing it.
So the search UI allows
access by location.
So if I'm looking for a
certain spot on the map
that I want to
evaluate, I can get
right to the information
that's pertinent to me
across the various assets
that I'm dealing with.
We use, for example,
a similarity search.
So that if I see a certain
pattern or a sort of intrusion
that might be of
interest to me, I
can quickly find all the assets
that have a similar pattern.
And all of that really is
about faster decision making
and better analysis.
Second use case, a bit
more text document heavy.
In this case, we're
dealing with mortgage
and really enabling that
automation of a very, very
manual workflow.
We all might think that this
stuff is all online now.
We fill it all out online.
You'd be surprised.
Most of it becomes paper
somewhere along the line.
So it's a very, very
heavy, manual process.
And as a result, it's
also a very slow process.
So this particular
use case is all
about taking a process from
multiple days to hours.
For this particular
use case, it's
also very illustrative of the
power of Document Understanding
AI.
What we're doing here is
we're looking at a loan file
and we're asking two questions.
Is it complete and
is it accurate?
So in order to decide whether
a mortgage balance is complete,
I got to understand
what documents I got.
Classify the documents.
Compare against a
list of per location
what's actually required.
What defines complete.
Making sure that all
those documents are here.
Now we dig in.
Is it accurate?
So this is where we have
to pull information.
Whether it's a name, a
social security number.
It could be an APR.
There are lots,
and lots, and lots
of extractions
that happen across
those different documents.
And two things.
One, do I have
everything filled out?
Do I have a signature where
I'm expecting a signature?
Do I have a name where
I'm expecting a name?
Do I have a stamp from a certain
maybe regulatory group that
needs to bless something.
All of those things
need to get checked.
Then I need to look
across the documents.
Do I have the same name with
the same social security
number in all of them?
Is the APR the same?
And essentially identifying,
did somebody put the wrong paper
in the wrong file or is a
document filled in incorrectly
or incompletely?
So document understanding helps
us to do all of those things.
And then from a workflow
automation perspective,
we can output that to
enable an RPA process that
now can be much, much more
automated, rather than manual.
So when you're
thinking about the top
of this particular slide,
all those little people,
that's where all the
time is being spent.
That's where the inefficiency
comes in for the processor.
That's where the wait time comes
in from a customer experience
perspective.
All right?
So we're really looking for
here is to drive better customer
experience for the
actual applicant,
as well as time and cost
savings for the processor.
And then finally, of
course, the automation
to enable the entire workflow
to be automated end to end.
The second thing that
is really important
is once we have all of
this rich information,
there are other use cases
that can be enabled.
So if a mortgage processor
wants to understand
how they are doing with respect
to compliance for fair lending,
they have all this
rich information
that they can now use to
understand how they're doing.
Are they actually
well positioned
or do they have an issue?
And what can they do about it?
So the analytics on top, once
we've done all of this work,
there are a myriad
of other use cases
that can be enabled for
that particular customer.
Another very document-centric
process is HR.
So employee records.
This particular use case
is focused on privacy.
So GDPR was mentioned.
So personal information
and complying with GDPR
really means you have to
be able to understand where
you have personal information
about your employees,
in this case.
And you have to be able
to get to it quickly.
An employee says,
hey, I want to know
what you are keeping about me.
What personal information
you're storing of mine.
I need to be able to get
to that content quickly.
I need to be sure that
I'm finding all of it.
And I need to be able
to actually give it
to the employee,
if they ask for it.
So processing documents
from various sources
and in various formats.
So I've been at Iron Mountain
for a really long time.
When I first got hired,
we filled out paper.
So my records
probably are in paper.
So pulling all of that in, being
able to image that content,
and allow that to be commingled
with content that may have been
collected electronically just
a couple of months ago or last
year is very, very important.
And being able to
have the ability
to understand where that
content in the document
is and whether or not
I'm actually dealing
with sensitive information
or personal information,
as opposed to just, here's a big
pile of stuff that may or may
not be relevant, again,
enables companies
to not only be compliant, but
be efficient in responding
to requests.
So the other thing
about these things
is you can't keep
stuff forever anymore.
So retention policy.
A lot of companies for
a long time the default
was, well, I keep
everything forever
so that way I'm not deleting
anything that I shouldn't be.
Well, GDPR actually ends the era
of everything forever retention
policy.
So now that we have
this information,
we have it classified
we understand
who it's for, when an
employee leaves the company,
we have an obligation
to actually
be able to get rid
of that information
within the retention period.
That is, within the compliance
for the privacy regulation.
So classifying the
content, understanding
that it is employee
information that
pertains to a
certain employee now
also allows us to get rid of
the information when we need to.
So that's where the policy
plus Document Understanding AI
really comes together to help
companies do the right thing
at the right time.
This next one I'm going to
dig into a little bit deeper.
Actually we hear it a
lot from our customers.
it Doesn't really matter
what kind of company you are.
You probably have
customer contracts.
We all hope we have many, right?
At Iron Mountain, that's
something like 400,000.
So very simple things
get really hard when
you're trying to do them across
a big, huge pile of stuff
like that.
So first of all, they tend
to be kind of distributed.
Different products and
services, different regions,
different acquisitions that
they may have come from.
So the stuff is
all over the place.
So simple, simple
questions like,
what are all the contracts
for this particular customer?
Already hard.
People poke around in
lots of different places
and they hope,
again, they hope they
find all the relevant
information, but they may not.
The other thing is
things like, well, who
has non-standard payment terms?
How do you answer that?
You get to read a
lot of documents.
That's how it's done today.
So then you look at
more complex questions
like, which contracts have a
limit of liability for data
breach above a $1 million?
And now we're looking at
Document Understanding
AI as a really,
really powerful tool
to allow those natural
language questions to actually
be answered.
So this particular use cases
where we worked very closely
with Google on using the
knowledge capabilities
that Sudherra introduced
earlier to really
empower users to find this
type of information very,
very quickly.
So let me show you
a couple of examples
that illustrate what
the UI looks like
and what the experience
is for a user.
So this is our simple,
I need all the contracts
for a given customer.
Now notice in this
case we're actually
dealing with a salesperson.
So another thing that
is really powerful here
is that there are multiple
stakeholders potentially
within your company that
need to access this content.
And we can allow each
and every one of them
to have the benefit of accessing
this rich information now
very quickly.
So in this particular
use case, you're
going from poking around,
asking people, getting
to different repositories,
to essentially one click.
What we've done is
anything that we
extract, we allow you to use
as a facet or as a widget.
I can pin those on my UI.
So if I'm usually looking
for things by customer name,
I can actually just pin
that right to my UI.
If I'm looking for
a certain customer,
start typing in the name
or just click on the one
that I'm looking for.
And all the documents that I
need are there with one click.
So incredibly efficient
to get to what still
is a fairly simple answer.
Second one, a little
bit more complex.
So now, who has
non-standard payment terms?
This is actually quite a
common issue for companies.
And it's incredibly
hard to get to.
So again, today,
first of all, I got
to find all of the contracts
in all the repositories.
But then, how do I figure out
what the payment terms are?
So I might do a
keyword search and I
get to the right section of
the contract, which I then
get to read.
So it's still very
manual, very sort
of a person doing lots
of reading to get to it.
Here what we can do is
narrow it down, perhaps
by customer if that's
what we want to do.
Narrow it down, perhaps
by agreement type,
so the classification
that we've done.
But then really looking at
the Document Understanding AI
to extract the
pertinent information
and letting me essentially
say, OK, well, you know what?
30 days is my standard
payment terms,
so anything 60 or
90, give me those
because those are the ones
that I need to focus in on.
Again, going from
who knows how many
hours of work, to a few clicks
that give me the right result
set.
And this is my favorite one.
So when you think
about contracts,
think about perhaps
an M&A scenario.
Just bought a company.
Your GC walks by and
says, hey, how many
customers within that population
that we've just inherited
have a limitation of
liability above $1 million?
How many have a non-standard
whatever clause it might be?
That generally is where,
forget your weekend,
you're going to be
reading for a long time.
And frankly in an
M&A case, there
is dozens of people
locked into a room
for could be days
could be weeks,
depending on how
big it is, literally
reading through documents.
So again, what we
can do here is define
what is standard,
what is non-standard.
We can look for those
things using the knowledge
capabilities that come with
the Document Understanding AI.
And extract that information.
And give it to the lawyers at
their fingertips within, again,
a few clicks.
With the ability to filter
based on different types
of documents, different
regions, if that's
what they're looking for.
All of that information is
literally a click to get to.
So I hope these use
cases illustrated
the power of Document
Understanding AI
and what we can do
to really drive value
for customers from using
these types of technologies
as part of our platform.
We think it's important
that we can deliver an end
to end solution, so that
customers can really
take advantage of
all of the benefits
that come with these really
advanced and great capabilities
that Google is
providing, and get
to a much faster time to value
than trying to sort of build it
all yourself, build a
UI, all of that stuff,
infrastructure,
all of those good,
fun things that go around it.
So again, the platform,
very flexible.
We think it's
important that you can
do that across
various content types,
from various content
sources, in various formats.
We have an example of
for example the marketing
department.
Those guys are
dealing with videos.
They're dealing with images.
They're dealing
with data sheets.
Lots of different content types.
But when I'm looking
for something,
it's usually not
by document type.
It's by topic.
I'm looking for a certain
country, for certain languages,
for a certain product.
But I want all the
content for that product
or for that language.
So again, very important to go
across those different formats
and types.
For us, again, defensible
compliant is very important.
So we want to make sure that
when you're classifying,
you're also able to
take advantage of that
so that you can drive
appropriate policy
for those documents.
How do I now leverage the
fact that I know what I have
and that I can use it?
But how do I also make sure that
I'm treating it appropriately.
That I'm retaining it
for as long as I need to.
That I'm protecting
it because it's
sensitive or
personal information
that I'm dealing with here.
And doing that in one platform,
across multiple stakeholders,
across multiple
different use cases.
So you do all of
the hard work once.
You classify, you enrich.
But then you benefit for
multiple stakeholders,
multiple use cases,
advanced analytics
on top, once I've done the
automation piece to start.
So I hope this was helpful
and illustrative of what
we're trying to do here.
And I'm going to pass
it over to Milan.
[APPLAUSE]
MILAN LEE: Good afternoon.
My name is Milan Lee, and I'm
a Machine Learning Specialist
at Google Cloud.
We've heard already how great
the Document Understanding AI
solution really is.
Let me go ahead and show
you the details of it,
the technology of it.
And I'll even show you a
quick demo on how it works.
So for my demo, I'm going to
be analyzing patents data.
[INAUDIBLE] attorney at
a patent attorney firm.
And I want to be able to gain
competitive insights on what
different companies are doing,
what their product innovation
roadmap is.
And one really
good source of that
is to look into patents data.
Patents actually have a lot
of rich information that you
cannot get anywhere else.
You cannot get from journals.
You cannot get from conferences.
Those are usually pretty
proprietary information,
but that happens to be shared.
So it really helps
me to understand
what are the active
players in the market
and for every single product.
The challenge of reading
through patents is enormous.
And let me explain to you
what those challenges are
and how we can use AI,
specifically within Document
Understanding AI, to help
us solve the problem.
So we're looking at two
different patents from the US
side by side.
For each patents, what's
really interesting to a patent
attorney is when
is a patent filed.
And there are various
dates within the patent.
So we have the date a
patent that was approved.
And we also have a date for when
the patent was initially filed.
For me, to automatically
extract those two key fields
are already really
worth to use AI for.
I want to be able to make
sure that when I extract out
those fields I can
properly populate them
in the database in
the exact column,
and in the exact format, and
not mix up those two dates.
We also see a lot of different
unstructured data on here.
So for example, we have
a title of the patent.
And the title itself
sometime is pretty generic,
but sometimes it's
pretty specific.
So I want to be able to extract
those key information as well.
And, of course, there
are illustrations
within the patents
that often tell us
what is going on
with this invention.
What are the components
that go towards it.
So what if I have a AI tool that
can help me to automatically
understand extract
out documents so
that I don't have
to manually review
it, do data entry for it,
and then crop out the image
and store it.
That would save me a
lot of human hours.
So this is a pretty
huge endeavor to do.
And what if I want to really
expand this work beyond just US
patents?
What if I want to start looking
at European patents that
also come in different
format from US.
They have different
nomenclature,
different fields, different
titles, different ways
of expressing things.
And let's go ahead
and couple this
with the challenge of
having different languages.
So we can have German, French,
in addition to English,
and many other
European languages.
How can we use AI to automate
the ingestion, understanding,
and processing of
all these documents
that are in different
formats, different languages,
and unify them in one
single environment?
That's really where
the AI would come in.
So let me just walk through
the lifecycle of understanding
a patent document.
And I wanted to add the caveat
that this is not the only life
that in the patent can adopt.
It really depends on
what your use case is.
But for my use case,
what I really want to do
is just to ingest data,
and then process it,
and be able to start
in a structured format.
So let's start off with
the ingestion layer.
So I want to be able to
find an economical option
to store all my new patents
and be able to archive
the old patents.
Every year in US alone there
are at least 600,000 patents
that are being filed.
So we really need a
scalable way to store
all these patents there
are currently in PDF format
into a raw storage area.
OK?
And this solution doesn't only
ingest documents in PDF format.
It can ingest pictures, images,
video, so forth, and so on.
So after we ingest
the data, I want
to be able to kick out
documents that are not
looking like patterns, right?
in this case, we really want
to use a computer vision model
to help us fine tune and kick
out those non-patent documents.
And then we'll move
on to the value
added process, which
is to apply OCR on it.
So OCR is just an acronym for
Optical Character Recognition,
which is used to detect and
extract the text in a image
and then write it out to a
raw format, raw text format.
So why do we need to extract
it to raw text format?
So it turns out
that there are a lot
of natural language
processing that we
can do on top of this raw text.
For example, we can apply a
content categorization model.
So what does that do?
It will basically scan
through the raw text
and it will identify what
is the topic of this patent.
So instead of me reviewing
the patent manually,
now we can use AI to help us
understand what the content is.
For example, is this patent
about medical technology?
Is it about cryptocurrencies?
Is it about computer vision?
Or is it about other things?
So we can have an AI to
automatically understand it
for us.
And then after that
process, we can extract out
the specific entities
that I'm interested in.
So those entities
could be the title,
the description of the
patent, the different dates
in the patent.
Anything that I want to define
as my super specific entities,
I can basically fine
tune it in my model.
And then I want to then
do object detection.
So object detection is basically
finding the images and signals
within the image or
PDF document and be
able to crop out
that image, identify
xy coordinates of that image,
and store it in the database.
And then lastly, you
have a structured way
to analyze the data.
So that's pretty much
what I want to go through.
Let's go ahead and run
a demo really quick.
I'm going to log into my system.
OK.
So I'm going to
launch a shell script.
This shell script
will basically help
me to invoke all the
AI services that I
will use to generate the
classification models, the NLP
models, and object
detection models.
And then I'll show you
the end outcome of it.
So I'll go ahead and
launch the script.
And I actually launched
it before the demo.
Can we go back to the slides?
So while this is
launching, while the shell
script is launching,
let me go through what
each model is doing.
So the first model is
basically classifying
between the European
patent, US patent,
and another category
called datasheet,
which is just more detail
specs about the patent itself.
So in order to classify
these specific categories,
we'll have to use a
custom model for it.
Because the generic
model that Google
has as an API will not be
specific enough for these three
categories.
So in my demo, I used a roughly
500 samples to train the model.
And I was able to get very
close to 100% precision
and 100% recall for
my model performance.
Those two metrics
are usually used
to determine how
robust the model is.
So with 500 samples, without
writing a single line
of tensorflow code, without
having to do any programming,
I'm able to fine tune my
model to differentiate
between the different patents.
So this is where I would
filter out the datasheets
and then move on to the
next value added process.
So we apply OCR on it.
So as you can see, everything
that was inside the patent PDF
is now converted to a raw text.
That's not really
interesting yet.
The next interesting
part is yet another AI.
We wanted to categorize to
content within the patent.
So by scanning
through the content,
being able to parse the
different sentences,
being able to draw semantic
meaning from the corpus
into text, we're able to
determine what is the category
or what is the content
for this patent.
So right here in my
demo, I only created
three different categories.
But this can be
as many categories
as you need for your
business domain.
And again, I only have to
train the model with very, very
few samples in order to get this
kind of accuracy and precision
in my model.
So what this is telling
me, for example,
is every time when I run a
model, when I invoke a model,
I would be able to get a
probability on whether this
is a pattern relating to
medical tech, cryptocurrencies,
or computer vision.
So given that we
know the content,
and then we want to extract
[INAUDIBLE] entities.
This is pretty hard to do.
Google has some
free trained APIs
to extract out common entities
like objects, names, landmarks,
et cetera.
But not really specific
to patent documents.
So this is where we'll also use
AutoML to fine tune the model
and extract out only the
information that I want.
So remember, this isn't
trivial because we
have different languages
for our patents
and we have different formats.
So the positioning
of the information
might be different among
all the patents you have.
With the AutoML, that's
within the solution.
We are able to fine tune
and extract the exact entity
that we need with a pretty
high accuracy for most
of the fields.
And then lastly, we want
to draw it down in box.
Again, this is very important
to understand illustration
of the invention itself.
So the object
detection technology
will basically
identify any objects
that you want to identify.
So let's say if there are
multiple objects here,
you can choose to identify the
most important object to you
and just extract that image
with the xy coordinates.
And finally, we saw how
we can kind of munch
around the unstructured data.
And then we finally
kind of arrive
to the destination, which is
to have a very structured way
to understand our data.
So in this case, I chose to use
BigQuery to store all the data.
This can be other kinds
of analytical database.
The destination can be
maybe another service.
For example, it
can be like this.
So this is within the Document
Understanding AI solution
that would help
to basically find
association and relationship
among your data.
So for example, I might
have multiple inventors
for a particular
technology and I
want to be able to
find relationships
among authors, inventors,
or among different content
area with my patents.
So knowledge service is
really helpful visually
to find those relationships.
SUDHERRA VANGURI:
Thank you, Milan.
Before I wrap,
quick show of hands.
So we've gone through
about 7 partner stories.
We've gone through
four key case studies
that [? Anka ?] has pointed
out in Iron Mountain,
and the patent use case.
How many of these
use cases resonate
with some of the
document processing
workflows you've seen in
your company or business?
Wow.
Pretty much everybody's working
with contracts, I assume.
How many of you have not seen
any of these document use
cases?
Have you missed any?
Wow, we've got everything.
Oh I see one.
Well, I hope that by
the end of the session
you are as excited as I am in
trying out some of our document
understanding capabilities.
Our partner integrations
make it really easy for you.
It's the fastest
time to value for you
to get these deployments
up and running.
We see that a lot of
companies across verticals.
To highlight a few we,
see energy companies that
try to automate some of the
geophysicists' workflows
and evaluate the risks
associated with new sites
use Document Understanding AI or
can use Document Understanding
AI to identify, let's say,
when [INAUDIBLE] parameters
within very technical
geophysical documents that
require a lot of ML expertise.
One of these providers can
use Document Understanding AI
to automate and
figure out what's
a servicing document, what's
an origination documents.
And we've seen that these
kind of classifications,
not just from
[INAUDIBLE],, our document
classification in general has
given up to 96% precision.
Egnyte, for instance,
has gotten 97.3%
precision on classifying
security documents.
Our health care companies can
use Document Understanding AI
in their clinical
trial processing.
There's a lot of
doctors' patient notes
that you need to analyze
that get very technical.
And you may want
to analyze, well,
what's a dosage amount,
or what's influenza,
or what's a certain symptom
within that patient note.
And we see these
vertical use cases expand
across multiple industries.
Contracts, for
instance, is omnipresent
across multiple verticals
And contract processing
is something that all
of these industries
can analyze using
Document Understanding AI.
And retail customers,
for instance,
can analyze customer feedback.
Think tweets, comments,
tickets, service
tickets that can be analyzed.
All of this
unstructured data can
be converted into
structured data
using our Document
Understanding AI tools.
With that, I'd love to encourage
you to try cloud.google.com
/solutions/docum
ent-understanding.
Please visit and
provide your feedback.
We're always amazed at what
new use cases our customers
come up with.
And sometimes we are
surprised by them.
So please feel free
to give us feedback.
I'll hang around for questions.
But thank you so
much for attending.
And hope you try our
Document Understanding AI.